[Music]
it's just important to to get the
opportunity to work on films like this
you know talking about real guys and
veterans who are coming back mental
health issues in your plana
a sergeant who's finishing three
deployments for us post-traumatic stress
you know and that's a really complex
issue and I hope that this movie kinda
yeah bring some attention to this to
this condition because millions of
veterans are coming back messed up and
we need to talk about it miles teller at
the premiere of his new film thank you
for your service in LA on Monday night I
was a good soldier I had purpose and I
loved it
these are our guys and men and women you
know and and we're telling their story
and also for the wives and the families
what it's like when your husband goes
off to war and he comes back a different
individual is there a specific incident
that troubles you newly-engaged are
brought along Beyonce Kelly Sperry who
stunned in white
yeah we're just we're enjoying the
engagement part
[Music]
you
[Music]